foreign
[Music]
hi everyone so glad you decided to join
us today for our program I'd like to
know
as probably most of you know this is a
question and answer program where you
send us your questions and we do the
research in attempt to answer the
questions that you send us uh let me
give you the email address where you can
send them to us it's a TV at some tv.org
you can see it there on the screen TV at
some
tv.org we'd be very glad to answer your
questions just be patient because we put
them in the order in which we receive
them and we have many many of them so
just be patient and we'll get to them
eventually and hopefully provide you an
adequate answer I have with me uh Pastor
David Salazar who is on our staff and he
basically spearheads the Latino Channel
although he does many programs in
English as well and that's a real
blessing to have someone who's bilingual
and thank you for being here thank you
Pastor is always a blessing and a
privilege for me to share this time with
you and learned together from the word
of God how how to answer the question so
that we get a lot from our friends that
are watching amen never should the Bible
be open without prayer amen so would you
have prayer for us absolutely let's pray
Heavenly Father we are delighted once
again to come to you at this moment to
seek your wisdom your word the
understanding of the scriptures and the
inspiration of the holy spirit that may
lead us into all truth I pray that you
will be your teacher our guide and what
we have to share with our friends may be
infused with the holy spirit so that the
words may come to them from you we pray
this in Jesus holy name amen amen
okay pastor we have a very interesting
question it's not a matter of life and
death it's not a matter of salvation but
I've had this question before it's sent
To Us by Cameron
Cameron Finn
um it doesn't say what location is from
but this is the question
who wrote Deuteronomy 34 verses 5
through 12. I understand Moses wrote the
Torah but this last portion of it
records events after his death correct
so who wrote These posthumous uh remarks
concerning Moses well the answer
probably is really found brighter in
scripture in the actual the Book of
Joshua
um as Joshua verse 1 chapter 1 verse 1
it sort of summarizes you know one verse
what verses
5 to 12 of the previous chapter what
explains of what happened to Moses how
he died he summarizes it there it says
now that after the state of the Moses
surrender the Lord it came to pass that
the Lord spake unto Joshua the set of
Nan Moses Minister saying Moses my
Syrian is dead neither for Rice go over
to Jordan and continue on with the story
so it's very clear from from this verse
that Joshua was instructed about the
death of Joshua of Moses and since
verses 5 through 12 in the previous
chapter in the last operation Army is
talked about the day of Moses we can see
that the Lord is the one that really
inspired him and show him what happened
to him and that's why he wrote it yeah
and and there's no uh issue when it
comes to this because uh Joshua and
Moses had spent the majority of the well
not the majority of their lifetimes but
Moses spent 40 years with Joshua in the
wilderness and then uh to the borders of
the promised land correct and so uh you
know nobody else other than Joshua could
write so accurately about where he was
buried right and uh and the fact that
the Lord buried him because that's an
interesting detail you know nobody knew
where his grave was
and secondly
the Bible tells us that God buried him
and and you know it's interesting
because he speaks when when we read like
verse 10 just you know he speaks the
whoever is writing about Moses how he
dies it also
shows that it was a personal lost as
well you know he says there and never
arose a prophet since the Israel seems
like Moses it's like he he really
admired that man and and when we can see
the story
Joshua he loved Moses he was better by
his side he will not depart from him you
know and that's the kind of thing that
sort of pointed out that Joshua is the
one that wrote that uh plus the Lord of
course showed him and told me yeah
Joshua knew that he was uh buried on
Mount Nebo yeah but nobody knew the
exact precise Place correct where Moses
was laid to rest right so that's uh
answer to this question from the word of
God
we have another question pastor this
comes from Alf Brownie and uh it says
the question can one live under grace
and the law at the same time and is
their biblical support
so this is a question in regards to
living under the law and under grace
let's see I I think he's you know taking
this from The Book of Romans chapter 6
and I'll let you start the answer to
this question
okay uh no doubt this question is coming
from verse 14.
um
let me just explain first of all that
when the expression under law
is used it's referring to under
condemnation of the law because of sin
this the law condemns us because we're
sinners
the law says if you break me yeah the
the reward is death okay right so under
the law here means someone who is under
the condemnation of the law
so you can be under law under the
condemnation of the law or you can be
under grace because Allah doesn't
condemn you because it condemned Jesus
in your place correct and you repented
confess to your sin and so on
so uh it says in verse 14 for sin shall
not have dominion over you correct
why
for you are not under law but under
grace
yeah and so so people read that verse
isolated
and they say
I don't have to worry about keeping the
law
because I'm under grace Jesus kept the
law for me
Paul knew that people were going to use
that argument so in the very next verse
he says the following
what then
shall we sin
because we are not under law but under
grace
certainly not and that is a double
negative in Greek it means no no don't
even think of it
not so exactly uh so so Paul is saying
okay we're under grace that means that
we now can sin because we're not into
the law but under grace he says God
forbid and then he says do you not know
to whom you present yourselves slaves to
obey you are that one slaves whom you
obey whether of sin leaning to death or
obedience leading to righteousness in
other words the grace of God does not
exonerate us from obedience absolutely
when we appreciate God's grace wow you
know that law said I was supposed to die
because I'm a sinner
but I received Jesus who took my penalty
upon himself now I'm under grace
it'll be our Delight to have escaped
death and to be obedient to Jesus but
obedience is the fruit of not the root
right correct obedience is the result
amen it is not the cause of our
salvation but a person who says oh I'm
under grace so I can break the law that
person is not truly under grace
absolutely and that's I guess the
confusion that you mentioned well Pastor
you will said the concept of being under
law in this verse particularly is about
the consequence of breaking the law when
you are condemned you are in
condemnation
when you receive the grace of God you
are free from the condemnation but you
are enabled by the power of God to obey
and follow his Commandments that is why
it mentions there even in verse 18 being
then made free from sin you become the
Servants of righteousness amen so there
is that clear indication from his own
you know writings Paul they're
explaining what really meant this
freedom of the law that's the
condemnation of the law not the aspect
of like you said just do whatever you
want and you know not having a law we
are with Christ obligated to follow his
footsteps if we follow the lord if we're
with him we are in that yoke of bond
with the Lord where we can follow and
fulfill his Commandments and do as he
says so it's I guess the answer can you
live under Grace under law if you speak
about the law of God you you'll be of
course Grace will enable you to follow
the law so you will be living in the
same time with both of them absolutely
lovely but under the condition of the
law and the grace no that cannot happen
yeah so you know when the Bible uses the
word walk figuratively it's talking
about conduct or behavior correct in the
previous context you have uh in Romans 6
verse 1. what shall we say then shall we
continue in sin that Grace May abound
so so that so that there's a lot of
Grace let's continue sinning the Apostle
Paul says certainly not the double
negative again right how shall we who
die to sin live any longer in it right
or do you not know that as many of us as
we're baptized into Christ Jesus were
baptized into his death therefore we
were buried with him through baptism
into death that just as Christ was
raised from the dead by the glory of the
father even so we also should walk in
newness of Life absolutely our conduct
in other words has to change absolutely
so being under grace leads us to
appreciate what Jesus did for us and we
will offer him voluntary and loving
obedience you know I have an example
practical example of this when I passed
in Fresno Central Church one Wednesday
evening we had a fantastic prayer
meeting you know we have testimonies and
we sang and we studied the Bible it was
great I was pumped up at the end of the
meeting I got in my car my my head was
in the clouds because of the glory of
the occasion and I turned the corner
onto First Street and I was a exceeding
the speed limit by 20 miles and so and
soon a patrol car came back I saw the
red and red and blue light
so uh the officer came to the window and
he said sir could I see your driver's
license please so I gave my driver's
license he says do you know why I
stopped you
I said well yeah I I figure that
probably it was because I was expeding
this the speed limit right exceeding the
speed limit he said yes you were going
20 miles over the speed limit
and um and I said really I'm sorry that
uh you know that I did that and then he
asked me uh you know what do you do for
a living
I was embarrassed to say well I'm a
passer and he says of all people pastors
should know that they should obey the
law but then I said I'm really sorry I
shouldn't have done it and then I told
him about prayer meeting that that was
really exciting thing I just come to an
end and you know I was pumped up he says
well but when you drive your brain
doesn't need to be in the clouds your
brain should be on the road right and I
said I I recognize that I'm really sorry
so he says well I know I'm going to tell
you what I'm going to do
because I see that you're sorry for what
you did
and it wasn't intentional
I'm going to let you off the hook this
time I'm not going to give you a ticket
praise the Lord oh I was saying
hallelujah praise the Lord I don't have
to pay the pay for a ticket right you
know he got in his car left and as I was
driving home I got to thinking
that officer did something that that he
should not have done mm-hmm
and say why he he had Grace you know he
forgave you uh so so that was Grace you
know and I said but wait a minute the
role of the officer of the law
is to punish transgressions of the law
right right
likewise the law of God
its responsibility is to punish
transgressions of the law correct
so he didn't do his duty
as a Lawman he should have given me the
ticket
and then I got to thinking
what would Grace be
Grace would be this
if the officer said sir
you broke the law
the law demands that you get a ticket
however I'm telling you what I'm going
to tell you what I'm going to do for you
I'm going to go down
to the court and I'm going to pay for
your ticket
um
let me ask you does the law receive its
just do
yes yes
but I didn't pay he did
okay that's Grace that's Grace you know
I didn't pay for my transgressions of
law
but the transgressions got paid because
Jesus paid them right now what would
what would you think if from that point
on
when I went around that corner said
Hallelujah I'm under grace now I'm going
to go 40 miles an hour over the speed
limit would you suppose that officer
would do if he came through Melinda says
aren't you the guy that I stopped last
night he's going to give me the ticket
yeah because being under grace
does not uh give me free license to
disobey the law of course you know in
gratefulness and to this day every time
I go around that corner
I remember the officer and I'm saying
whoops I better slow down and I better
go slow not because I'm afraid of
getting a ticket but I'll have respect
for that officer for giving my debt and
so that's Grace when somebody else pays
and out of gratefulness I am faithful in
obeying the law amen wonderful testimony
I think that's really really what it
what really Grace is about and we need
to remember that that we have received
the payment by Christ
but at the same time he gives us the
opportunity and the ability through his
grace that Grace enables us to also
follow his Commandments
all right so let's continue with the
next question
this is interesting question that comes
from uh Mathias masawi and he sends out
the question in regards to Resurrection
he says is resurrection referred to in
John 5 28 and 29 the same as that of
Daniel 12 2.
are these texts talking about the
special Resurrection which takes place
before the second coming of Christ
so I think we should go to those two
verses pastor and just kind of uh
answer this question that is a very
interesting question in regards to the
second or the special Resurrection the
special resurrection that happens prior
to Jesus coming for a second time
John I have that John 5 28 to 29.
and I'll read says Marvel not at this
for the hour is coming in the which all
that are in the graves shall hear his
voice and shall come forth they that
have done good and to the resurrection
of life and they that have done evil and
to the resurrection of them Nation
so is this verse uh then he says Daniel
12 2.
that talks about the
um that many that are in the Sleep verse
two says in the dust the Earth shall
awake some to everlasting life and some
to shame an everlasting contempt so is
this talking about the second or the
special resurrection that happened prior
to just coming
well we need to explain what the special
Resurrection is
uh the special Resurrection takes place
when God delivers the living Saints from
the death decree at that same time right
a certain group a special group is going
to resurrect it's not the general
resurrections there's a general
resurrection of the righteous at the
second coming and there's a general
resurrection of the wicked after the
Thousand Years of course but this is a
specialized group that rise from the
grave when God delivers the living
Saints and uh basically uh Daniel
chapter 12 verse 2 makes it clear it
says in many not all many of those who
lie in the dust of the Earth shall arise
some to everlasting life and some to
Everlasting conditions yeah right so so
in other words this is not the general
resurrection and Jesus is speaking about
two resurrections the general
resurrection of the righteous and the
general Resurrection action of the
wicked correct the Apostle Paul referred
to this as well in Acts 24 and verse 15.
if we can go there acts 24 and verse 15
also said that there are going to be two
two resurrections
um
do you have it um you've got it here 24
15.
it says I have hope in God which they
themselves also accept that there will
be a resurrection of the Dead both of
the just and of the unjust
so there's going to be two resurrections
now in John 5 Jesus did not tell us the
time period between the two right
we have to go elsewhere in the Bible to
know how much time will will transpire
between the resurrection of the
righteous and the resurrection of the
wicked now where do we find the uh time
period in between well there's in
Revelation
chapter 19 or 20.
speaking of the Thousand Years between
one or the other
we can see that in verse actually uh
[Music]
uh
the uh I find it okay see here is the
verse in chapter 20 verse six places and
holies he that part in the first
resurrection
on such the second that had no power but
shall be praising of Priests of God and
of Christ and shall reign with him a
thousand years okay and then when
certain years are expired Satan will
shall be loose out of his prison so it
sort of gives you the or verse 5 even
tells you that there's a thousand years
also before one or the other so it
really clearly defines the resurrection
of the wicked
a thousand years after their second
coming of Christ after a social of the
righteous so the question is now is
there a special resurrection and when
that happens or if that is speaking of
that verse I mean there are those verses
in John speaking of the special
Resurrection
uh I don't know if we can make that
assertion you know from this
specifically because he's not really
giving uh a statement of such thing yeah
um you know uh in going back to
Revelation chapter 20 yeah
um clearly
you have two resurrections spoken of
here yes uh separated by a thousand
years right because verse 4 says and I
saw Thrones and they sat on them and
judgment was committed to them then I
saw the souls of those who had been
beheaded for their witness to Jesus and
for the word of God who had not
worshiped the Beast or his image and had
not received his mark on their foreheads
or on their hands and they lived which
means that they must have been dead they
lived and reigned with Christ for a
thousand years so that resurrection of
the righteous takes place before the
Thousand Years began because they're
going to reign with Christ for a
thousand years correct but then verse 5
tells us something very interesting it
says but the rest of the Dead
did not live again until the thousand
years were finished so if the first is
the resurrection of the righteous yeah
who must be the rest of the Dead
the the wicked I mean you know that's
the only absolute answer there's
nothingbody else yeah so so there are
two resurrections which is what Jesus is
referring to in John 5. the first
resurrection is it's mentioned first
Thessalonians chapter four The Lord
himself will descend from heaven with a
shout with the voice of an archangel the
trumpet of God the dead in Christ will
rise first they'll be caught up in the
air to meet Jesus in the air and then
they will take it be taken to the New
Jerusalem for a thousand years as
Revelation 20 says correct Jesus did not
tell us the time period between the two
resurrections you have to go to the Book
of Revelation for that right and that's
a very important uh biblical principle
of study and that is you don't stay in
one verse no of course you look at all
of the testimony of the Bible and then
you have a complete picture the special
Resurrection is a different one and we
know that because in the special
Resurrection
um those who Pierce Jesus are going to
resurrect correct and that becomes clear
in Matthew 26 64 where Jesus says to
Caiaphas you're going to see the son of
man coming on the Clouds Of Heaven well
in order to see him he must resurrect
correct also in Revelation 1 verse 7 it
says he is coming with the clouds and
every ice shall see him and those who
Pierce him correct so that that is a
special group of wicked people because
we already notice that the rest of the
Dead do not live again until the
thousand years are finished right and so
uh Jesus is not referring in John
chapter 5 to the special resurrection of
a certain group of wicked and a certain
group of righteous he's referring to the
to General resurrections of the
righteous at the second coming and of
the wicked after the millennium now
Pastor what would you think that
people have
um you know a hard time understanding
this concept of of Resurrection in
regards to some get confused with the
what the frustration is and what the
Declaration is what do you think there
is this this problem sometimes to
understanding why these two
resurrections are then I mean I'm amazed
you know I've heard people saying that
the resurrection of the wicked uh in
Revelation it's only of a certain group
of people it's not going to include uh I
don't know people that were not ever
heard of Christ but is it really just a
resurrection of those that had a chance
to know the Lord or really includes
everybody you know what what would that
be God would not condemn anyone
unless they had an opportunity to know
the truth and rejected it
so basically those outside the holy city
which the Bible says are like the sand
of the sea yeah they are the wicked from
all ages those who had the opportunity
to know or knew and rejected the light
because God would not condemn them if
they did not have an opportunity if they
did not have the light which would lead
them on the right path
and also in Romans chapter 1 and chapter
2 speaks of those that never heard of
Christ necessarily but they have no
excuse either because the works of
creation will talk to them about sure
you know the Creator in heaven so even
if they've never heard of Christ
they have the chance to at least know or
live according to the knowledge that was
available to them through the creation
through what they will see in the
elements that nature tells them but I'm
but that's why they don't have an excuse
either so they will be resurrected as
well I mean you know so it's not just
limited to those that had a chance or
heard of Christ but everybody every
human being that uh could have known
something about the Lord and rejected or
didn't hear their voice yeah we do not
have a monopoly on the Holy Spirit the
Holy Spirit works with with people who
are never
never had a Bible
but the Holy Spirit speaks to their
conscience right and and sometimes the
Holy Spirit uses uh the second book of
God which is the book of nature clearly
you can see that there was a Creator if
you have an open mind and heart even if
you're you don't have a Bible
uh things did not come into existence by
chance right and so the Romans chapter 1
says that they're without excuse correct
Because by the things that were created
they could see that there was a creator
and so but God is not going to condemn
anyone
who did not have a chance to know the
truth by the way God does not judge us
on the base of the light that we had but
on the basis of the use that we made of
the light that we had because if we had
the light and we didn't use it yes you
know we're still going to be condensed
absolutely so so basically
um the two resurrections are the all of
the righteous at the second coming
and all of the wicked I did after a
thousand years with a special
Resurrection at the second coming
those who died in the faith of the third
Angels Three Angels message and those uh
who
um
well basically those who believed in the
third Angel's message and the other
group those who Pierce Jesus are going
to resurrect to see him coming in the
clouds and that's a an amazing
um promise I suppose to those that are
living today for us that are living
today if the Lord takes us to to sleep
if that's the case you know if he sees
in his will had if we have preached and
lived according to the greatest message
we will be resurrected to see him come
in the Clouds Of Glory so that's a real
amazing thought if we can actually start
thinking what the Lord has in store for
for us who have learned the truth in
this time any other last thoughts and
for God
the resurrection already happened
because all live to him Amen to that so
that's how sure we can be be for us the
resurrection is a promise for God it's a
done deal praise the Lord praise the
lord well we are out of time and we
thank you once again for sending your
questions may God bless you and your
family may you continue to strive to
learn from the word of God and to spend
time with him
thank you